[MUSIC PLAYING]
KARTHI THYAGARAJAN:
Hello, everyone.
My name is Karthi Thyagarajan.
I'm a solutions architect
with Google Cloud Platform.
So I'm going to talk about
Cloud MemoryStore for Redis,
as well as OpenCensus today.
First, Cloud
MemoryStore for Redis.
It provides a fully managed
in-memory Datastore service
that's built on scalable,
secure, and highly
available infrastructure
that's managed by Google.
Now, caching capability,
as most of you know,
is extremely important for
most production applications,
and latency goes
hand-in-hand with caching.
The way most people reduce
latency is using caching.
Now, tracing this latency
in an end-to-end fashion
for your application is
the role of observability.
And it helps you design
your application faster,
and it will also help you
diagnose issues faster.
Now, I should point out that
Cloud MemoryStore for Redis
already has powerful monitoring
capabilities built in,
but this is entirely
on the server side.
In this video,
what we'll look at
is how you can build
observability of attributes,
like end-to-end
latency, directly
into your applications with
something called OpenCensus.
OpenCensus is a
vendor agnostic set
of libraries that
provides metric collection
as well as tracing capabilities.
So before we get
to our demo, let's
look at the application
architecture.
Our application is a simple
three-tier application,
and it's hosted on
Google Kubernetes engine.
At its core, it consists of
a simple Java Spring Boot
application, and users interact
with this application via GCPs,
https Load Balancer.
And for the database
here, our application
uses Cloud SQL, specifically
the MySQL engine in Cloud SQL.
When the user issues a query
against our application,
the results returned
from the database
are cached using Cloud
MemoryStore for Redis.
With that context, let's
see the demo in action.
So in this application,
what we'll do
is we will look for our
employees in our directory
by typing in part of their name.
In this case, we'll
type in Mel, and we
see that a whole bunch
of results are returned.
In addition to those
results, we also
see that the application tells
us how long that query took,
248 milliseconds in this case.
Now, let's try that query again.
Type in Mel again, and
as you can see now,
it only took one millisecond.
That's because the
results were cached
in Cloud MemoryStore for Redis.
Let's dive a little
deeper into it
by looking at what
OpenCensus tracing tells us.
We've configured OpenCensus
to perform trace logging
into Cloud Trace, which is a
service offered by Google Cloud
Platform.
Navigating to
Cloud Trace, we can
see that our trace logs are
easily identifiable by the name
of the function that we used.
And in this case,
it also tells us
how long the overall function
took, 248 milliseconds
approximately.
OpenCensus tracing also
lets us dive deeper
into our overall function call.
You can see here that our
application attempted to get
the results from the cache--
in this case, Cloud
MemoryStore for Redis
did not find it in the cache,
hence the request to MySQL.
Down below, you can see that
MySQL took approximately 244
milliseconds, about twice
the order of magnitude
that it would take to
fetch the data from Redis.
We can also see
here that we have
annotated cache misses
to help us better trace
our application.
Diving a little deeper into what
happens after our results are
fetched from MySQL, you can
see that our application
added the results to the
cache using addToCache.
What about the second
time the query is issued?
We expect the results to
be fetched from the cache,
and that's what we see
using OpenCensus tracing.
We can see that this query
took a lot less time,
around one millisecond.
Because the results
were found in the cache,
it did not have to
access the database,
and we saved approximately
240 milliseconds.
That's quite a bit of time.
So that was the happy path.
You can see how we also have
library level tracing here.
Now, let's see how
OpenCensus can help
us diagnose issues that occur.
What we'll do here is we'll
simulate a network issue where
we cannot reach our Redis host.
And we'll type in
the name Mel again.
While we expect this to take a
lot less time because we expect
the results to be
in the cache, we
see that it actually takes
240 milliseconds or so,
so there's something wrong
with our application.
There's too much latency.
So let's go back to
OpenCensus tracing
and look for the
most recent request.
Diving deeper into it, we see
that there was a cache miss,
and the reason
for the cache miss
is that our application was
unable to connect to Redis.
Now, in production, we would
have to chase this error down,
and it would be a lot
more difficult to find
the error without this
tracing capability.
Now, we know that it's a
network issue or some kind
of connectivity issue getting
to Cloud MemoryStore for Redis,
and we know where to
focus our efforts.
So that can save us a lot
of time during diagnosis.
Hopefully, that
gives you an idea
of how you can use OpenCensus
for both improving performance
as well as diagnosing issues.
To summarize,
we've looked at how
you can use Cloud
MemoryStore for Redis
to significantly reduce
latency in your application.
Following that, we
also saw how you
can build in end-to-end
observability
directly in your application
using OpenCensus.
If you're interested in using
OpenCensus in your application,
please visit opencensus.io.
So thank you for watching.
If you enjoyed this video,
please click the Like button
and subscribe to this channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]